foreign
[Music]
my name is Tim Knutson and I'm the
director of product management for xero
trust here at Google Cloud Security
First of all thanks for joining me today
and today I'll be speaking about what's
new with xero trust and in particular
about a topic I think that's top of mind
for many of you as I've spoken with a
lot of customers over the last number of
months and that is around this idea of
zero trust coverage and the reason why I
frame it this way is because in a lot of
the conversations I'm in when it comes
down to is how can you achieve across
all of the use cases coverage with zero
trust so that you can achieve that
security posture in the compliance that
you need to for your organization so as
I've reflected on these different zero
trust coverage conversations it really
was broken down into kind of three main
buckets and that is clouds devices and
ecosystem and what I mean by that is in
clouds we're talking about
can I provide zero trust for my apps
regardless of where they live devices it
can actually provide zero trust whether
it be from a managed device or an
unmanaged device an ecosystem that's all
about how can I bring this all together
with my current or possibly future
Investments so I have one holistic zero
trust approach on on one zero trust uh
architecture
so let's get into the first topic which
is around
clouds or multi-cloud so first update
here is over the last couple of months
we've been working on this we talked
about this in the last next and some of
our our Summit events and now I just
want to let you all know that with
beyondcorp as you can see here our
ability to provide access uh for not
only gcp apps has now been further
expanded to provide access for apps that
are seeing outside of gcp and connecting
to those apps over a various set of
options it could be over an interconnect
over a cloud VPN or now with our new app
connector over the Internet this gives
you the flexibility to connect to those
apps regardless of where they live based
on the option that you want to choose
we've also expanded our support for what
apps we can support
we've continued to support our
browser-based access which is very
flexible and provides an easy set of
options of course for both managed and
unmanaged we've also expanded that
support to also provide Legacy app
support so that for those apps that are
still in your ecosystem that aren't
browser-based Beyond Corp can also
provide support for those as well when
as part of your Azure trust use case
coverage
now the next thing I want to talk about
is around devices
so with devices uh what we see of course
is the questions of how can I support
managed
um but also heavily
the theme is around what how what can I
do for unmanaged the reason why that's
becoming such a big theme is because
most organizations have a monitor to
oftentimes can be large contractor
um set of of individuals that they need
to provide access to both SAS
applications and private applications as
well as back to kind of the theme of
coverage organizations are also trying
to make sure that they have a strategy
in place to handle the scenario if the
managed device is no longer functional
but they still need to provide secure
access to those critical applications
needed to run their business so we've
been doing a lot of thinking about how
to solve this problem
and in particular how do we solve for
this for the unmanaged device
um and the constraints that we've really
put into this consideration is how can
we approach this without requiring
agents because again it's an unmanaged
device deploying an agent is not easy in
many cases not even acceptable how I can
do this without having to require a
proxy in place uh how can we do this so
we support any device regardless of the
user the third party be first party
um in regards to where the users are
connecting from
and this is where we've brought together
the marriage of what we've done with
Beyond Corp and it's zero trust access
capabilities and protections for data
and threat with Chrome browser so
together we can provide a very secure
way for Enterprises to browse uh SAS
applications critical for business
operations as well as private
applications but our Focus here is
specifically on SAS applications as a
starting point and that's with what
we're we've done with Beyond Corp
Enterprise Essentials and with this
combination of Chrome browser secure by
Design Beyond Corp and it's zero trust
capabilities we're now able to offer a
very rich set of security capabilities
and protections
all through a browser Chrome browser
without requiring agents proxies
supporting all os's for all of your
users whereas to their first party or
whether they're contractors
if you think about the capabilities
built into this let's go through each
one of those so you have a little deeper
insight into what we're offering with
this approach
so as we break this down further the
first thing we want to solve for is how
do we provide secure access to SAS
applications as we thought about this
the thing we wanted to take advantage of
is the fact that we have a control point
on the device with Chrome browser and we
have the ability to make a context aware
decisions in line with the
authentication path of the SAS
applications and with that we're able to
collect signals from the device using
our present using Chrome browser and
other
environmental understanding in terms of
location of user
geography and use that as all part of
the context set
to make that context aware
decision on whether or not to allow or
deny that users access to SAS
applications whether it be workspace or
other SAS applications
with that that's kind of step one and
these policies are very flexible you can
you can adjust some percept SAS
applications per groups so that you have
the ability to be very specific in what
policy you want to set for each of those
those access
groups now the next thing we've thought
about is well there's one thing to
provide zero trust access to the SAS
application but what else can we do for
the unmanaged device when it comes to
protections starting with data
protections and again this is where
we're taking advantage of the fact that
we have the combination of Chrome
browser on the device with
Beyond Corp and with Chrome browser and
our built-in data protections we offer a
rich set of ways to protect that
valuable information as being viewed or
exchanged with the SAS applications from
that and managed device because in the
browser we have the ability to do DLP
for both files being uploaded and
downloaded to protect sensitive
information from coming out or the wrong
information going in we also have within
the browser other data controls and
these are protections allow us for
example to stop copy and paste or other
protected information from coming in or
out of the browser is again we have the
leveraging Chrome browser
highly ubiquitous in nature as that
control point on that unmanaged device
and we've also considered obviously the
user experience aspects what do we tell
the user if they're being blocked or
denied from a particular action we can
you can configure it to trigger warnings
straight blocks and you can also modify
the messages so they're more custom to
the user experience that you want to
deliver
so if I think the next step we've taken
in thinking about this holistic approach
for unmanaged devices is how do we
handle threat protection because we look
at this problem it's a layered problem
first how can we control access second
how can we apply protections for data
third what else can we do to ensure that
we're reducing the risk and that's where
the threat protections for malware and
for phishing all leveraging Google's
safe browsing come into play which takes
advantage of the factors deployed across
5 billion devices already we're not
bringing that power into the Encore
Essentials for the purpose of providing
a comprehensive solution of access and
protections for unmanaged devices
but if you then take it a step further
back to making this practical and
operational for you and the Enterprise
we've also looked at how we can provide
visibility
again leveraging that foothold that we
have with Chrome browser we're able to
provide visibility into the devices the
users what activities being generated
what actions are being taken in advance
as a function of both our controls on
the data side and threat side all in a
very rich reporting format so that you
have that same visibility you'd want for
a need for managed devices now also
available for unmanaged devices
and this approach also provides a way
that you can actually
offer your users the ability to use
Chrome as is you can use Chrome for
personal work and you can use Chrome for
your Enterprise purposes because through
the availability of multiple profiles
you have the Enterprise profile and you
have the personal profile with the
Enterprise profile this is where we're
able to force all of the policies we
just talked about in terms of access in
terms of data in terms of threat
protections so that's the profiles used
for those purposes but that is not the
profile that's used of course for for
non-work related
or personal uses and in fact you can
have multiple profiles for worked or
Enterprise use cases so that you in the
case that uh there may be separate needs
across different
um Enterprise needs and while we've been
focusing on the unmanaged device here
this same capability can also be
provided for managed devices
and as a whole what we're offering to
this combination of beyondcorp
for zero trust access
and the built-in data protections
the remote Cloud management so basically
making you with through Chrome browser
and unmanaged device effectively
unmanaged device for purposes of setting
policy for purposes of visibility
um purposes for management
um with Chrome browser itself secure by
Design we now have a comprehensive way
of providing secure Enterprise browsing
for your unmanaged devices as well as if
you want to use it for your managed
devices
now let's move on to the next topic
which is around ecosystem
ecosystem is something that we've been
very uh focused on from the beginning in
fact as you may recall back when we
first started with Beyond Corp
Enterprise one of the things that we
launched was the beyondcorp alliance and
the whole purpose of the alliance was to
recognize that you are pulling together
a zero trust solution that oftentimes
involves multiple different products
Technologies and tools but I'll focus on
one single outcome that is getting to
zero trust coverage
um so what we'd like to announce today
is that we've expanded our collaboration
with Palo Alto networks and prism access
and this expanded collaboration in
Partnership is all about being able to
take
our Beyond Corp Enterprise Essentials
which as I just discussed provides you a
very comprehensive unmanaged device
solution that provide secure Enterprise
browsing for SAS applications plus the
Best in Class ztna solution with prism
access for managed devices to provide
the most comprehensive solution for zero
trust all powered by gcp
and this allows customers now to
expand their zero trust coverage using
the solutions such that you have an
approach that will solve both for your
managed devices with prism access as
well as for your unmanaged devices using
beyondcorp Enterprise Essentials
together giving you that zero trust
coverage uh so that you can deliver that
security posture uh that you that you
need across both your managed devices as
well as unmanaged and this takes
advantage of course of the reach the
scale the built-in protections for DDOS
low latency Network they're all part of
the gcp platform on which both
beyondcorp and prism access are deployed
and together
it gives you a comprehensive set of zero
trust capabilities
in particular for the unmanaged device
where we as we spoke about gives you
that
zero trust contextual access to SAS
applications
all through Chrome browser leveraging of
course the facts that you can control
what data is going is uploaded
downloaded
what the controls within the browser
from print copy and paste
the threat protections all through a
centralized management and done without
requiring another browser another agent
and something that can equally be
extended to your hybrid as well as your
first party Workforce regardless of
where they are
so bring it all back
as we thought about how to help you in
our own investments in expanding our
zero trust capabilities we've really
been focused on how it can help you with
coverage how do we help with use case
coverage to get you to to zero trust and
across clouds devices and ecosystem
we've been working to introduce a set of
capabilities that allows you to get to
all clouds that gives you a
comprehensive solution for unmanaged
devices so you can ensure secure
Enterprise browsing for SAS applications
with secure access and data protections
and expanded our work in our ecosystem
specifically with Palo Alto networks and
prism access so you can have a
comprehensive zero trust solution
it covers substantial number of use
cases for both unmanaged and managed all
powered by gcp
so thanks again for joining me today to
hear about what's new in xero trust I
encourage you all to check out some of
our other sessions in particular uh hear
more about from our Google cyber
security action team or gcat about some
of the the capabilities they're offering
when it comes to helping you through
your zero trust Journey with Discovery
sessions workshops recommendations and
implementation services
that's all for now thank you very much
for joining and see you next time
[Music]